صفقه ثلاثيه ستغير الوجود العسكريه في
منطقه المحيط الهادئ وتجلب اليها غواصات
بالدفع النووي
الاتفاق الثلاثي بين كل من استراليا
والولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
سيؤمنبيرا 5 غواصات نوويه خلال العقد
القادم من طراز يو اس اس فرجينيا
والغواصات البريطانيه الهجوميه
وما يميزها هو صعوبه الرصدها وامكانيه
السفر لمسافات طويله بالاضافه لقدرتها على
حمل الصواريخ عابره للقارات
الصفقه جزء من تحالف اوكوس الثلاثي
الهاتفي الى تشارك التكنولوجيا العسكريه
والذكاء الاصطناعي الذي يضم الدول السابقه
تحالف جاء عام 2021 كانت فعلا على نشاط
الصين المتنامي في المحيطين الهندي
والهادئ
اتفاقيه اوكوس تدور حول المستقبل كما انها
تطفي طابعا رسميا للقيم والمصالح المشتركه
لدولنا الثلاث
اعتبرت المشروع الجديد خطيرا هادفا الى
حصارها رد فعل مشابه لاعلان تحالف اوكوس
عندما ادانت الخارجيه الصينيه التصدير
التكنولوجيا النوويه الامريكيه الا ان
كبرى دول اسيا كانت قد اعلنت عن زياده
بنسبه
7.2% من ميزانيتها الدفاعيه لعام 2023
لتكون اكبر زياده منذ العام 2019
اذا عمر العربيه